ein drittel unseres gesamten lebens
verbringen wir menschen schlafend und
damit genau hier startet man einen neuen
tag und beendete dort wieder es lohnt
sich also diesen ort perfekt zu machen
vor zirka zwei jahren haben wir zum
einzug in unsere wohnung unser altes
zurückgelassen und dieses massive
holzbett gekauft gesagte
1749 euro für diesen stolzen preis
sollte es aber wirklich perfekt sein
oder ja nicht ganz und da der balken
gästezimmer bekommen und wir deswegen
ein zweites brauchen kam die idee ins
spiel einfach selbst eines zu bauen rein
optisch gesehen ist unser aktuelles bett
für sophie und mich das schönste das wir
uns vorstellen können ich habe
tatsächlich recht lange auf google
bilder und interest nach designer betten
gesucht aber jedes mal wenn ich eins
gefunden habe das mir gefällt was
einfach genau das dass wir schon haben
aber natürlich ist das aussehen nicht
das wichtigste warum sollte ein weg
einen getränkehalter haben oder
eingebautes wireless charging fürs handy
genau so was kann man eigentlich nicht
unbedingt kaufen aber man kann sich
selber bauen und genau das habe ich vor
es wert gestellt hat um die 1800 euro
gekostet und eine lieferzeit von
zweieinhalb monaten gehabt ich bin mal
gespannt ob ich das nicht vielleicht
sogar ein bisschen günstiger und vor
allem viel schneller hinbekommen dieses
video wird er unterstützt von emma ich
verwende designtechnisch also als
vorbild unser aktuelles bett und messe
zuerst alle maße ab tatsächlich sind es
auch gar keine massiven holzbalken
sondern quasi fake balken die aus 1,8 cm
dicken brettern bestehen eine ähnliche
konstruktion bei euch also erstmal am
computer nach den hohlraum der durch den
balken trick entsteht mache ich mir zu
nutzen für ein kleines fach in dem man
zb eine augenmaske ein geldbeutel und
sonstigen kram reinlegen kann außerdem
kann ich dadurch von unten eine kleine
aussparung in das obere brett fräsen in
die wir ein wireless charging module
einbauen können ich war übrigens super
überrascht wie easy rider star team
funktioniert ich wusste ja dass da eine
spule verbaut ist aber das ist wirklich
nicht mehr ist als einfach ein zehnmal
gewickelt rat hat mich schon echt
geschockt so sieht dann jetzt das
fertige bett gestellt quasi hier am
computer aus wenn ich jetzt noch ein
paar kleine letzte änderungen im
feinschliff macht ist nun schon
unterwegs im baumarkt um verschiedene
schrauben locker für scharniere leim und
natürlich vor allem eine menge holz zu
kaufen
[Musik]
so dass eine menge holz würde ich sagen
soll ich habe hier ein paar zeichnungen
und ich fange mit den langen teilen an
und dafür brauche ich als allererstes
mal zwei meter lang und 1 38 breit und
damit ich weiß was abgeht beschäftigt
jetzt mal an sich existiert das bett ja
schon aber bisher eben nur am computer
und auf den zeichnungen jetzt übertrage
ich also genau diese zeichnungen auf
unser holz und damit die linien entlang
denen ich später segen werte sowie
position für bohrungen und zwar mit
diesem ding namens streich mast dass ich
mir vor kurzem zugelegt habe mit denen
das echt super schnell geht nachdem das
geschafft ist kommen die maschinen zum
einsatz die werkbank
[Musik]
kümmern wir uns mal um das wireless
charging ich habe vorhin getestet das
wireless charging durch 4 mm dickes holz
noch funktioniert also gehe ich auf der
unterseite des holzes mit einem loch
bohrer runter bis auf 4 mm und fräse
dann das loch schön glatt mit einer so
genannten over freese hier kann nun die
induktionsspule passgenaue reingelegt
werden und das handy damit idealerweise
von der anderen glatten seite geladen
werden ob das jetzt wirklich
funktioniert sehen wir später
so guten morgen in der werkstatt ich
werde erst mal saubermachen den dreck
von gestern
[Musik]
so nachdem das büro als endgültig zu
einer werkstatt verkommen ist habe ich
mich jetzt mal alle teile für den ersten
balken zurechtgelegt und ja der beiden
will sich jetzt eher schummelt aus
verschiedenen brettern bord das sieht
echt stark aus also das ist echt krass
ausgeht dass hier direkt verschmilzt das
magazin auf ordentlich und schon hat man
sich aber hier so ein balken gefegt und
das würde jetzt sagen werde jetzt einmal
verleimt und
jetzt der große moment beiden hälften
zusammengeschoben nun etwa was die
dicksten schraubzwingen
[Musik]
so und das ist es jetzt eine weile aus
herten
dicken fake balken sind fertig und
tatsächlich habe ich mir gerade kinder
genauer auf jeden fall sind die
tatsächlich ultra schwer natürlich nicht
so schwer wie sie ernähren wenn sie
unten massiv werden sehr sehr nahe ist
allerdings gibt es noch ein paar
unebenheiten die nicht so perfekt auf
einander ständig sind deswegen wird das
nochmal abgeschliffen damit so ein paar
stellen die nicht ganz genau gearbeitet
waren noch etwas schöner werden und
natürlich auch die kanten hier ab damit
es nicht ganz so weh tut wenn man mit
dem knie drauf steigt wie ich jetzt
gerade eben danach wird die oberfläche
noch mal mit einer stahl bürste ein
bisschen uneben gemacht damit die
maserung des holzes noch mal richtig
schön rauskommt und eben nicht so
komplett politisch nachdem das alles
erledigt ist kann das holz im natur look
ordentlich konserviert werden und zwar
mit einem guten ertrags- und hier im
feuer nachher vergleich sieht das holz
vorher schon fast grau aus guten morgen
ich muss an der stelle ich mal gesagt
hat dass eingeölte holz dem komplett
geil aus das ist aber eine ganz andere
liga ist davor so und das ist jetzt
alles fahren komplett geil ich finde es
sehr wohl trainers aus um diese ecken
übergänge die sehen auch richtig richtig
schöne aus jetzt müssen wir zusammen
geschraubt werden vorarbeiten auch hier
eingezogen werden und ich würde sagen
ich nehme einmal los ich kann es kaum
abwarten mich da rein zu legen
[Musik]
und jetzt mache ich die füße dran
wie soll das grundgerüst ist fertig und
sieht ultra schöner aus ich bin komplett
überrascht warum auch immer ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass ich so gut hinkriegt
wie vor wir jetzt aber den ganzen
technischen schnickschnack herr einbauen
will ich mich erst mal ein bisschen rein
legen um zu schauen ob das alles so
passt aber naja so richtig bequem ist es
aktuell noch nicht let's go
perfekt
das wichtigste an im bett ist natürlich
die matratze deswegen hatten wir immer
die 25 hybrid matratze geschickt die ihr
euch auch holen können über den link in
der video beschreibung und mit dem coach
tommy sogar mit fünf prozent rabatt die
matratze schon im alten westen wenn ich
bin so einfach echt ultra bequemer 25
hybrid matratzen haben eine verbesserte
atmungsaktivität hochentwickelten
adaptiven diskurse schaum mit memory
effekt für optimale druckentlastung und
die bezüge der matratzen können ja sogar
abnehmen und einfach waschen
bei emma findet ihr aber nicht einmal
kratzen sondern auch kissen topper
lattenroste und sogar ganze betten falls
ihr euch nicht wie ich einst selbst
bauen wollte
ihr könnt die matratzen ganze 100 echte
probeschlafen um zu schauen ob es
wirklich das richtige modell für euch
ist und wenn er sie behaltet habt ihr
zehn jahre garantie auf den matratzen
kern egal ob ihr seiten bauch oder
rückenschläfer sei zwar immer ist für
jeden schlaf und körpertypen etwas dabei
mit dem coach tommy alte tier über den
link in der video beschreibung fünf
prozent rabatt und top zu allen anderen
rabattaktionen auf webseite für die
nächsten sechs monate in deutschland
österreich und der schweiz so ich habe
das problem dass ich mich gerade ein
bisschen tue elanvoll aufs bett geworfen
hat und dir einmal ein crashtest mit und
das ist tatsächlich gebrochen deswegen
kommt das gute stück noch einmal ganz
kurz raus ja so und um dafür zu sorgen
dass es nicht direkt nochmal passiert
muss ich etwas machen was eigentlich
jeder betten bauern immer macht etwas
anders ich auch gedacht habe aber wo ich
mir dachte brauche ich nicht ruhig
scheinbar doch war auch einfach dumm von
mir und zwar messe ich jetzt weil hier
die höhe des lattenrost ist der ist hier
auf 16 zentimeter höhe und das zeigt
nicht mehr jetzt mal kurz an ja und dann
sehe ich das jetzt
[Musik]
und das ist natürlich alles auch
befestigt werden warum also nicht mal
kurz die passenden schrauben was gar
nicht so leicht sein dürfte diese eine
kiste mit unzähligen schrauben okay ist
doch leicht doch mal kurz bohrungen
haben kannst neues werkzeug und
eigentlich kann ich auch mal diese neuen
schraubzwingen aufsätze yusen
mitzukommen aufsetzen damit dass heute
nicht verkratzt wird man jetzt kann ja
vereinbaren und dann rein trauben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt kann ich das ding auch relativ
easy darunter schieben
ich brauche deine hilfe und dass wir
setzen verrückte vorschlag aber wir
müssen das jetzt einmal machen kannst du
das kurshoch halten genau die mitte und
ein bisschen absetzen ja ok aber noch
nicht andere seite doch und ja also
vielleicht komme ich jetzt darunter
china der nicht gefehlt
ich glaube das müssen wir machen
ganz normal leben
ja
das wird dann irgendwann eng dass das
was wir brauchen ist eine seite auch
noch so was und
du willst wenn ich hier eine art männer
kommen nicht mehr weiter ich muss echt
aus aber die bewegen können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
felix ich bin ein idiot
na ja wir können das pad auch einfach
aufstellen
ja ich glaube auch
[Musik]
soja also das funktioniert auf jeden
fall deutlich besser
[Musik]
so das ist doch ein fest da passiert gar
nichts
[Musik]
was auch wir können das auf smarte
machen wir können auch actually das
leben also wir können schon kippen aber
ich würde beim kippen ein bisschen
hochleben also mit ihnen nicht die ganze
kraft auf den füßen legt
das ist doch jetzt geholt so
als ich glaube jetzt soll deswegen
ziemlich fest sein zu erstmals
laszlo i dropped ist man jetzt noch mal
die sonne bricht nicht
[Musik]
das ding
es knarzt nicht mal so schlimm
[Musik]
erst geht an die lehne daher jetzt
gerade diese beiden metallgestell hier
schön gebohrt noch mal was kann ich hier
eben einstellen wie groß der abstand
zwischen den ballen sein soll weil ich
will kein bisschen jetzt brett sondern
hier einen schönen abstand haben
vielmehr sollte aber nicht sein sonst
passen wir die winkel nicht mehr 3,5 3,5
ich wollte mal deine hilfe kannst du dir
einfach so nehmen ja ich glaube das
passt eigentlich wollte
wie lang kannst du das zu halten
gut dann mal mit direct die burgen rhein
werden jetzt einmal tatsachen geschaffen
sich zieht es aber zu recht hier
[Musik]
die jetzt hier
ja ich habe ganz loslassen so auch jetzt
sieht außerdem stinknormalen bett 1
smartpad wenn man so will hier kommt
dann eben strom rein damit kann man sich
über das handy aufladen aber man kann
das handy auch viel cooler aufladen ja
letztendlich die drauflegt
lebt das volk
und das hat richtig krass vaduz hat von
hier oben gar nix so ein idealer weise
kann ich jetzt wenn ich mich hier ins
bett legt das handy haben wir so
hinlegen zack und dann lädt das und das
ist total geil war kein kabel brauchen
kann aber geschlafen und kann ich dann
wieder nehmen kannst du da hinlegen
wohnt ja das ist doch echt sehr sehr
geil jetzt aber magie weil es so aus als
würde das holz ein handyladen was gar
keinen sinn was
natürlich im keinen guten bett fehlen
darf sind die leds die natürlich per app
steuerbar sind und zum rest der wohnung
passen
[Musik]
nein hier ist paul einer der cutter vom
thomas und weil der schon unterwegs ist
für eines der nächsten videos sagt ich
euch jetzt kurz wie das selbst gebaute
bett denn so im vergleich mit dem
designer besser abschneidet das hatte
ich eine lieferzeit von zweieinhalb
monaten da war thomas mit fünf tagen
aber deutlich schneller und auch
günstiger denn das selbst gebaute stadt
etwa 1800 euro nur knapp 7 184 euro
gekostet und so sitzt dann aus das
fertige wettig wenn es mehr als genug
ich hätte niemals gedacht dass es so
cool wird weil es ist wirklich
tatsächlich geil es ist einfach komplett
geil ich hab einfach es kam mir dann
noch ein bett gebaut dass der
tatsächlich richtig geil ist mit
wireless charging leds hier drunter die
ich per app erwarte ich hinten jede
beliebige farbe steuern kann aber hier
sind türkis finde ich tatsächlich
eigentlich am schönsten vielen dank auf
jeden fall an emma für legale matratze
den link zu der webseite findet ihr in
der beschreibung und ich muss zugeben
nach dieser ganzen arbeit hab ich mir
diese erholung in dem neuen bett jetzt
auf jeden fall verdient es ist schon
spät
[Musik]
[Applaus]